[Música]
vamos a hablar de economía aquí en
France 24 por ello me acompañan el
estudio mi compañero Luis Méndez Luis
bienvenido vamos a empezar hablando de
mercosur que por estos días ha sido muy
nombrado Así es Valentina básicamente
porque desde su llegada al poder el
presidente de Brasil Luis Ignacio tulula
Silva ha sido enfático en sus
intenciones de acercarse a los países de
la región y no ha ocultado su deseo de
relanzar mercosur pero lo hace en medio
de tensiones entre los miembros que ya
se han calmado acuerdos detenidos y el
estancamiento en la expansión del bloque
regional pero realmente decayó mercosur
los números refieren que no su informe
2021 y estamos a la espera de los datos
de 2022 reflejan que su intercambio
comercial creció y se valoró en
598.899 millones de dólares en su
totalidad con una balanza de pagos
favorable de 78.709 millones pero para
conocer Qué pasó realmente con mercosur
en los años recientes cuál economista y
profesor universitario Ricardo rosten el
destino del mercosur depende de lo que
haga Brasil o sea en realidad si uno se
pone a pensar qué fue lo que pasó
en los últimos años en el mercosur fue
justamente que
el presidente bolsonaro no
no tenía entre superioridad de
fortalecer un arcosur surge primero
como un acuerdo político
Entonces
desde ese punto de vista uno dice Bueno
ahora uno como un acuerdo político entre
Argentina y Brasil entre alfonsín y
sarney en esa lógica
uno entiende
que era que fortalecer el mercosur sería
conveniente Luis en ese proceso de
expansión de mercosur podría estar la
retoma del acuerdo con la Unión Europea
Así es Valentina recordemos que ambos
bloques se establecieron un acuerdo en
2019 pero este no ha entrado en vigor de
hecho el presidente de Brasil ha
manifestado en días recientes y
especialmente durante su encuentro con
el presidente de Uruguay Luis la calle
pop que para el mercosur es importante
lograr poner en vigencia el acuerdo con
la Unión Europea previo a cualquier otro
acercamiento pero veamos que pros y
contra tendría este acercamiento en
realidad el problema que tenemos entre
el mercosur y y Europa es que Europa
quiere que se abran las quiero un Libre
Comercio en términos de productos
industriales Argentina y también Brasil
creo están más interesados en
fortalecer el comercio de productos
agropecuarios y en realidad
políticamente en Europa es bastante
difícil eso porque el sector
agropecuario allá en Europa son
políticamente bastante importantes Luis
usted estaba haciendo mención justamente
de la reunión de Lula da Silva con la
calle Pou en qué radicó la importancia
de este encuentro Valentina para ello
tenemos que recordar lo que fue la
reunión del mercosur celebrada en
Paraguay en julio de 2022 donde hubo
mucha atención por el hecho de que
Uruguay tenía intención de discutir un
acuerdo comercial con china pero fuera
del bloque Lula respaldó este
acercamiento pero reiteró que prioriza
el acuerdo con la Unión Europea a
nuestro especialista de consultamos
sobre las posibilidades y los beneficios
de este acuerdo para el bloque mercosur
sería bastante beneficioso sobre todo
porque a diferencia que lo que pasa con
la Unión Europea los chinos lo que
quieren son alimentos
entonces que lo lo que primero el
principal producto de exportación del
mercosur ahora donde Sí hay un problema
es en que el acuerdo sea
no desde el mercosur sino de países
individuales
porque entonces
ahí hay un problema que viste como como
vos Debes saber el mercosur
es una Unión aduanera que
fomenta o mejor dicho posibilita el
libre comercio entre los países miembros
bueno Y en este contexto Lula también ha
mostrado interés en que Venezuela
regrese a este mercado común recordemos
que esta nación Sudamericana afronta una
suspensión por parte del Consejo del
mercado común Pero escuchemos qué fue lo
que dijo nuestro especialista al
respecto
parece que
acuerdo o mejor dicho esta intención
de volver a
a incorporar a Venezuela
al mercosur es más una estrategia
política pensada en términos políticos
que pensar en términos de los beneficios
del intercambio que generaría entre
Venezuela y el resto de los países de
Luis pasa usted muchas gracias por toda
esta ampliación de la información
económica un placer Valentina